Boom! Boom! Boom! Oh, that's a nice one. That's a nice one. That is, that's wonderful. Welcome to ADSP The Podcast, episode 63, recorded on January 15th, 2022. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we solve a Wordle Live. Okay, don't hate me. Sorry, I'm late. Let me turn my mic around. All right. I cut out of the last edit of episode 60, Bryce being 21 minutes late. But that that doesn't matter because today he set
砰！砰！砰！哦，这个不错。这个不错。这个，这太棒了。欢迎收看 ADSP 播客第 63 期，录制于 2022 年 1 月 15 日。我的名字是康纳（Connor），今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯（Bryce）一起现场解谜 Wordle。好吧，别恨我。抱歉，我迟到了。让我把麦克风转过来。好的。在第 60 期的最后剪辑中，我把布莱斯迟到 21 分钟的片段剪掉了。但这，这没关系，因为今天他创下了
a new record ladies and gentlemen it's 2022 new year new bryce more late than ever 54 minutes to be fair this time like i gave you like a heads up that i was going to be a little bit late admittedly oh i mean yes last time i't know, last time you did too. Did you? I don't know. I don't remember. I felt worse about being late this time, if it makes you feel any better. It's okay.
一个新的纪录，女士们先生们，现在是 2022 年，新年新布莱斯，比以往任何时候都迟，迟到了 54 分钟。公平地说，这次就像我提前通知过你我会迟到一会儿，诚然，噢，我是说，是的，上次我——不知道，上次你也这样。是吗？我不知道。我不记得了。如果能让你心里好受点的话，我这次迟到感到更糟糕。没关系。
You don't have to feel bad. I was working on my slide deck for the pre-recording for my meetup on Monday, so. What are you talking about? We're starting a new book, seven languages in seven weeks by Bruce Tate. They cover, what are the seven languages? What are the seven languages?
你不用觉得不好意思。我当时在为周一聚会的预录制制作幻灯片，所以。你在说什么？我们要开始一本新书了，布鲁斯·泰特（Bruce Tate）写的《七周七语言》（Seven languages in seven weeks）。它们涵盖了，哪七门语言？哪七门语言？
Yeah. Good question. I probably, no quiz time. Okay. Let's see if I can go through it. Hang on. Seven languages in seven weeks.
对。好问题。我可能，不，问答时间。好吧。看看我能不能背出来。等等。《七周七语言》。
I've got it right in front of me. I do have the slide deck on my computer, but it is in the background now. It is a pragmatic guide to learning languages. And hang on. I've got them here. And I assume that they're in order. All right. So why don't you go?
我手头就有一本。我电脑上确实有幻灯片，但现在它在后台。这是一本学习语言的实用指南。等等。我这里有。而且我假设它们是有顺序的。好吧。那你为什么不去呢？
Ruby? Correct. IO? Correct. We're going to go out of order now. We're going to go to the end. Haskell. Yeah, Haskell is the end.
Ruby？正确。IO？正确。我们现在不按顺序来了。我们要直接去最后。Haskell。对，Haskell 是最后。
Then Clojure. What position do you think Clojure is at? If you didn't say that was the second one from the end, that means it's third from the end? No, you got it. It was second from the end. It was second from the end? I'm going backwards now. So Ruby, IO, Haskell, Clojure. Scala is one of them. second it was second from the end okay i'm going backwards now uh so ruby io haskell closure uh
然后是 Clojure。你觉得 Clojure 排在第几个？如果你没说那是倒数第二个，那就是倒数第三个？不，你猜对了。它是倒数第二个。它是倒数第二个？我现在倒着来。所以是 Ruby、IO、Haskell、Clojure。Scala 是其中之一。它是倒数第二个。好吧，我现在倒着来，呃，所以是 Ruby、IO、Haskell、Clojure，
scala is one of them prologue's another one yeah that's six and the seventh one i definitely know it i created all the logos for these or not created i put them in a slide deck. What is the seventh one? We'll cut out the silence. Ruby IO, Clojure, Haskell, Scala, Prologue. There's one prototype language, one logic programming language, four functional languages. So what are the functional languages? functional language is closure haskell scala i'm missing a functional language i don't know what is it um it's erlang ah erlang yeah i should have known that because prologue joe armstrong wrote the foreword to the book and and he was consulted on both Erlang and Prologue. He's known for being the creator of Erlang, but for folks that are familiar with Erlang, they'll know that Joe Armstrong first fell in love with Prologue and then basically wanted to
Scala 是其中之一，Prolog 是另一个，对，那是第六个，第七个我绝对知道，我为这些创建了所有的徽标，或者说不是创建，我把它们放进幻灯片里了。第七个是什么？我们把沉默剪掉。Ruby、IO、Clojure、Haskell、Scala、Prolog。有一种原型语言，一种逻辑编程语言，四种函数式编程语言。那么函数式编程语言有哪些？函数式语言是 Clojure、Haskell、Scala，我漏掉了一种函数式语言，它是什么，嗯，是 Erlang。啊，Erlang，对，我本该知道的，因为 Prolog，乔·阿姆斯特朗（Joe Armstrong）为这本书写了序言，而且他在 Erlang 和 Prolog 这两门语言上都被咨询过。他以 Erlang 创建者的身份闻名，但对于熟悉 Erlang 的人来说，他们会知道乔·阿姆斯特朗首先爱上了 Prolog，然后基本上想要
create some kind of concurrent Prologue system. So Erlang is heavily influenced by Prologue, which is well known by folks that know Erlang, but not well known by folks outside of the Erlang is heavily influenced by Prolog, which is well known by folks that know Erlang, but not well known by folks outside of the Erlang world. So you know what we've got to do next? We've got actually, oh, oh, wait. So wait. I like how we both have probably different ideas of what we're going to do next. I know what you're gonna say but that's not actually actually you know what we can come back to what i want to talk about if if we'll do what you want to do and let me guess is it wordle it is where i've been i've been holding off for a full 10 hours and 59 minutes folks let me tell you i do it on so uh avid listeners will remember that Connor is a Scrabble expert because it was like the only game, the only video game that his mother let him play as a kid.
创造某种并发的 Prolog 系统。所以 Erlang 受 Prolog 影响很深，了解 Erlang 的人对此都很清楚，但在 Erlang 之外的人却——Erlang 受 Prolog 影响很深，了解 Erlang 的人对此都很清楚，但在 Erlang 世界之外的人却不是很清楚。所以你知道我们接下来要做什么吗？我们其实，哦，哦，等等。所以等等。我喜欢我们俩对于接下来要做什么可能有不同的想法。我知道你想说什么，但那其实——其实你知道吗，如果我们做你想做的事，我们可以回到我想谈的话题上来，让我猜猜，是 Wordle 吗？是的，Wordle，我憋了整整 10 个小时 59 分钟，各位，让我告诉你们，我是怎么——所以，呃，热心听众会记得康纳是拼字游戏（Scrabble）专家，因为这是他妈妈在他小时候唯一允许他玩的游戏，唯一的电子游戏。
Like, sorry. Computer game. Scrabble. Yeah, only a computer game. Scrabble expert really undersells it. Connor is like a Scrabble savant. Like apparently there's like competitive Scrabble. And I'm just going to go out there and say that Connor is like is ranked. I'm sure he's actually not. But like he could be if you want.
抱歉。电脑游戏。拼字游戏。对，只有电脑游戏。拼字游戏专家真的太低估他了。康纳简直就像个拼字游戏奇才。显然还有竞技拼字游戏。我要直说，康纳是有排名的。我敢肯定他其实没有。但如果你愿意，他完全可以有。
I have actually it's sad. I've been to Carcassonne Nationals. I'll just throw that out there. Canadian Carcassonne Nationals. I've never been to Scrabble Nationals. What is Carcassonne? We'll talk about that in another episode. But for those that know about Carcassonne, they're going to be like, oh, that's cool and very nerdy. Don't look it up. I have a book club with my sister in two hours. So we've got a limited time. I also have plans in three hours. We'll talk about board games. We'll do a board games episode.
我其实——这很可悲。我去过卡卡松（Carcassonne）全国赛。我就随口这么一说。加拿大卡卡松全国赛。我从没去过拼字游戏全国赛。什么是卡卡松？我们在另一集里聊这个。但对于知道卡卡松的人来说，他们会觉得，哦，这很酷也很极客。别去查了。我两个小时后要和我妹妹进行读书俱乐部活动。所以我们时间有限。我三个小时后还有安排。我们聊聊桌游吧。我们做一期桌游节目。
Oh, yeah, that'll be awesome. We'll do a board games episode. Oh, yeah, that'll be awesome. We'll do a board games episode in the future. And we have to leave a little time for me to talk to you about my plans because I have a very, very fun. So really, this isn't going to be two hours of recording. It's going to be like 45 minutes of recording, and then we're going to turn off the mics and then chat about other stuff. But yes, I love Scrabble. And I have to say, I absolutely love this game. It's the best. And so the Scrabble skill that I think is going to be most transferable here is going to be in first word selection. Because that is key to being good at Wordle.
哦，对，那太棒了。我们做一期桌游节目。哦，对，那太棒了。我们以后会做一期桌游节目。我们得留点时间让我跟你聊聊我的计划，因为我有一个非常非常有趣的计划。所以实际上，这不会是两个小时的录音。大概只会录 45 分钟左右，然后我们就会关掉麦克风，接着聊别的东西。但是，是的，我喜欢拼字游戏。我必须说，我绝对喜欢这个游戏。它是最棒的。所以我认为在这里最能派上用场的拼字游戏技巧将是在第一个单词的选择上。因为那是玩好 Wordle 的关键。
Yeah. I've played only eight times. I've never lost yet because I only discovered this eight eight days ago um and i've used the same word every single time it's interesting you just yeah and i bet you you put a lot of thought into what this word is uh a tiny bit but i actually think it's more second second word is more second word selection is more important i think that's where that's where people go but i i feel like first word selection is most important because it's like a shot in the dark, and you need to pick a word that both has letters that have a high frequency of appearing in other words
是的。我只玩了八次。我还从没输过，因为我是在八天前才发现这个游戏的。我每次都用同一个单词。有趣的是，你只是——我敢打赌你在这个词上花了很多心思。呃，有一点，但我其实觉得第二个词更重要——第二个词的选择更重要，我认为人们就是在那里——但我感觉第一个词的选择最重要，因为这就像盲人摸象，你需要选择一个既包含在其他单词中出现频率高的字母，
and also that has letters that appear in positions that they're commonly found in other words. It's like a balancing act between the two. I think it's – I mean, well, like, the reason I think that the second word selection is more important is because I already have my first word selected. I just realized we need to explain briefly what Wordle is for our listeners who might not know. You go ahead, you go ahead.
又包含常见位置字母的单词。这就像是在两者之间走钢丝。我认为是——我的意思是，好吧，我之所以认为第二个词的选择更重要，是因为我已经选好了我的第一个词。我刚刚意识到我们需要向可能不知道 Wordle 是什么的听众简要解释一下。你来吧，你来。
No, no, no, you got to do it. Okay, Wordle is a combination of Mastermind and Words. It's a brilliantly designed game. Whenever someone comes up with something like this, I'm like, damn it. I could have easily programmed this. But the ingenious of the game is that it's so simple and it's just a twist on a couple different things. So for those of you that don't know, Mastermind is a game where you have eight colors and there's a code maker and a code breaker. And the code maker chooses four pegs. They can either have four unique colors like red, orange, yellow,
不，不，不，你来解释。好吧，Wordle 是《天才密码》（Mastermind）和《密码》（Words）的结合体。这是一个设计精妙的游戏。每当有人想出这样的东西，我都会想，该死。我本来也能轻松编程出这个。但这个游戏的精妙之处在于它如此简单，只是在几个不同的方面做了一点小小的变通。所以对于那些不知道的人来说，《天才密码》是一个有八种颜色的游戏，有出题者和破译者。出题者选择四个钉子。它们可以有四种独特的颜色，比如红色、橙色、黄色、
green, or they can do red, red, yellow, yellow. Or they can do all, you know, red, red, red, red. And you have like, I think, I don't know what it is, 10 guesses. And basically every time you put down a guess, let's say my first guess is blue, purple, yellow, green. I got yellow and green correct, but in the wrong positions. So there's white pegs to let you know when you've guessed correctly in the wrong place, and there's red pegs to let you know when you've guessed the right color in the right position. And so based on that information over time, you can logically deduce what the know, what the code is, hopefully. Wordle is the same thing, but you're given six guesses in total.
绿色，或者它们可以是红色、红色、黄色、黄色。或者它们可以全部是，你知道的，红色、红色、红色、红色。你有，我想，我不知道是多少，10 次猜测机会。基本上，每当你下一个猜测，比方说我的第一个猜测是蓝色、紫色、黄色、绿色。我猜对了黄色和绿色，但位置不对。所以有白钉来让你知道你猜对了颜色但位置不对，有红钉来让你知道你猜对了颜色且位置正确。根据随着时间推移得到的这些信息，你可以逻辑推导出来，你知道的，代码到底是什么，希望如此。Wordle 也是一样，但你总共只有六次猜测机会。
Mastermind, there's a lot more. And you're given five letters. And each time you guess, it will let you know if you have a correct letter in the correct position or a correct letter in the wrong position. And that's about it. So basically, you have six guesses. Typically, I don't think with my first word, I've ever had a complete miss, which is indicative of that my first words being good. But like, the reason why I actually think that the first word's
《天才密码》的次数要多得多。而且给你五个字母。每次你猜测时，它都会让你知道你是否有字母正确且位置正确，或者字母正确但位置错误。差不多就是这样。所以基本上，你只有六次猜测机会。通常，我不认为我的第一个词完全猜错过，这说明我的第一个词选得很好。但是，为什么我其实认为第一个词
not that important is because I think that there's a ton of good first words. You could debate whether mine is the best. I think it's a very good one. It's in the top 1%. But does that mean that there's not an actually statistically better one? I don't know the answer to that question. I think the reason that the second word is more important is because a lot of the times when you get, you know, and so green means correct position, correct letter. Yellow means correct letter, wrong position. Usually you get one or two of those. I typically always try to include those in the next guess.
没那么重要，是因为我觉得有很多很好的第一个词。你可以争论我的词是不是最好的。我认为这是一个非常好的词。它在前 1% 里。但这是否意味着没有一个统计学上更好的词呢？我不知道答案。我认为第二个词更重要，原因在于很多时候当你得到，你知道的——绿色代表位置正确、字母正确。黄色代表字母正确、位置错误。通常你会得到其中一个或两个。我通常总是会把这些包含在下一次猜测中。
So then the hard part is coming up with a word where the four or three letters that are new letters are also high likelihood letters. Yeah. And a lot of the times finding a word that, you know, fits that criteria isn't always trivial. And yeah. So how are we going to do this? Are we just to play silently no no we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna share our screen and we're gonna we're gonna do this together oh whoa whoa whoa whoa together that but then but then that's going to be cheating that's going to be cheating or so i see we're going to play this together at the same time. So I can
所以难点在于想出一个包含三四个新字母，且这些新字母也是高概率字母的单词。是的。而且很多时候找到一个符合这个标准的单词并不总是那么容易。是的。那我们要怎么做呢？我们是就这样默默地玩吗？不，不，不，我们要分享屏幕，我们要一起做这个。哦，哇，哇，哇，哇，一起做，但那样的话——那不就成作弊了吗？那不就是作弊吗？或者，我看明白了，我们要同时一起玩。所以我
still count this. Yeah. Although, although, see, this is the thing. Are you influencing my picks? Because I'm undefeated. I've never lost this game. I'm eight for eight. Well, well, well, well, yes. This is, this is, we're going to, we're going to demonstrate pair programming and problem solving techniques. I play mine on my phone, so I will play along on my phone. Okay. All right. So what is your first word?
还是可以算进战绩里。对。不过，不过，看，问题就在这里。你在影响我的选择吗？因为我保持不败。我还没输过这个游戏。我战绩是八战全胜。好吧，好吧，好吧，是的。我们要展示的是结对编程和问题解决技巧。我在手机上玩我的，所以我也在手机上跟着玩。好的。好吧，你的第一个词是什么？
My first word is tears. T-E-A-R-S. Tears. I feel like that's a good one. You've got the S at the end, which is pretty common for words you know, for words. You've got two vowels. Yeah, I like that one. I like that one. All right. All right. So let's, let's see what happens. All right. We've got an A, not in the third place. Okay. So, and this is, this is my strategy is I always try to get, uh, in this case we have,
我的第一个词是 tears。T-E-A-R-S。tears。我觉得这个词不错。结尾有个 S，这在你知道的单词里很常见。有两个元音。是的，我喜欢这个。我也喜欢这个。好吧。好吧，让我们看看会发生什么。好的。我们有一个 A，不在第三个位置。好的。所以，这就是我的策略，我总是试图去——在这种情况下，我们有
we have one vowel. So I always, if I've missed both E and the A, I always try and get another vowel. Yeah. Two new vowels being the O and the I. But so like, I think yesterday's word and people can't go back and play this in the past. So it's okay to talk about it. I think yesterday's was tangy. So we got T in the right position yesterday and A in the wrong position. And then my second guess after that was Talon because L, N are two good ones to guess. And then O is I prefer I, but I couldn't really think of a decent word that had an I that also had like an... How many guesses did you get it in yesterday? Yesterday, I got it in three.
一个元音。所以如果我和 E 以及 A 都失之交臂，我总是会尝试获取另一个元音。是的，两个新元音是 O 和 I。不过，我觉得昨天的词——人们不能回去玩过去的词，所以聊聊也无妨。我觉得昨天的词是 tangy。所以我们昨天在正确的位置得到了 T，在错误的位置得到了 A。在那之后我的第二个猜测是 talon，因为 L 和 N 是两个很好的猜测对象。然后 O 是——我更喜欢 I，但我实在想不出一个既有 I 又有... 你昨天猜了多少次才猜中？昨天，我猜了三次就中了。
Yeah, me too. But from like my second to my third, my third guess being Tangy, like I was not expecting to just get it right there. I don't even know why that came to me, why Tangy came to me. All right, so what are you thinking we should do here? Ideally, what I want is a word with a D, an N, an I. A D, an N, and an I. Why those letters? Because, I mean, if anyone watches Wheel of Fortune in the final round, R, S, T, L,
对，我也是。但从我的第二次到第三次猜测——第三次猜测是 tangy，我当时真没想到能直接猜中。我甚至不知道这个词是怎么蹦出来的，为什麽 tangy 会出现在我脑子里。好吧，那你觉得我们现在该怎么做？理想情况下，我想要一个包含 D、N、I 的单词。一个 D、N 和 I。为什麽是这些字母？因为，如果有人看《幸运轮》（Wheel of Fortune）的决赛轮，R、S、T、L、
N, E, I actually don't like L as much, but R, S, T, and N are definitely like very high. Like this is a game of statistics. So D, N, like because D shows up at the end of words all the time. Although now that we don't have an E, it's less likely. But I like an I is A, I, and E are definitely the three most common vowels. So whenever I can get an I in there. So it's all about trying to like optimize. Sorry, say again which letters you want. You want D, I, N.
N、E——其实我没那么喜欢 L，但 R、S、T 和 N 绝对是高频字母。这就像是一场统计学游戏。所以 D、N，因为 D 总是出现在单词的末尾。虽然现在我们没有 E，可能性就小了。但我喜欢 I——A、I 和 E 绝对是三个最常见的元音。所以每当我能把 I 放进去。所以这一切都是为了尽量优化。抱歉，再说一遍你想要哪些字母。你想要 D、I、N。
D, I, N. Reuse the A and put it in a different spot. My first thought was diner, but that's, of course, not good because it wastes two of our letters. Oh, yeah. Never, ever guess a letter that you already know is not there. They even gray it out on your keyboard in order to help you from guessing it again. That's a very – I mean, in some cases, you might have to if you can't think of a word um how about how about um how about no that doesn't fit um so like think of a word that ends in nd yeah that's a good good way to think about it yeah uh like so like another guess actually we
D、I、N。重复使用 A，把它放在不同的位置。我的第一反应是 diner，但这当然不好，因为它浪费了我们两个字母。哦，对。永远、永远不要去猜一个你已经知道不在里面的字母。它们甚至会在你的键盘上将其灰显，以防你再次猜测。这非常——我的某些情况下，如果你想不出一个词，你可能不得不——那——那——那——不行，那不符合——所以像想一个以 nd 结尾的词，对，这是一个很好的思考方向，对，像——另一个猜测其实我们
could do and i've actually never done this we could ignore the A for now and guess a word like found. Actually, I don't like found because F is low probability. So you're guessing, I don't like, I need an I. I need the I. You need the I. Although like guessing,
可以这样做：我们暂时忽略 A，猜一个像 found 这样的词。其实，我不喜欢 found，因为 F 的概率很低。所以你在猜——我不喜欢，我需要一个 I。我需要这个 I。你需要这个 I。尽管猜测——
that's a pretty good strategy at this point because we have very little information. How about, so you need an I, yeah. Nadir. That has an R at the end, though. Land. Landy. Yeah, see, that's the problem.
在这一点上这是一个相当不错的策略，因为我们掌握的信息很少。所以，你需要一个 I，对。Nadir。不过它的结尾有一个 R。Land。Landy。对，看，问题就在这里。
I can think of plenty of words that end with N-D, but they're all four letters. And then I want to stick an S on the end of them, and that doesn't help us. Oh, think of something A, like basin, but without an S in the middle. Yeah, yeah, I see what you're saying. Cigar. Also has an R in it. Yeah. We're going to have to cut some of this out.
我能想出很多以 N-D 结尾的词，但它们都是四个字母的。然后我想在它们后面加个 S，这可帮不上忙。哦，想一个带有 A 的词，比如 basin，但中间没有 S。对，对，我知道你的意思。Cigar。里面也有一个 R。对。我们得把这些剪掉一些。
This is... No, no, no, no. This is all staying in. We're just going to have a Wordle episode. Yeah. Two software engineers. Way overthink playing the game. I feel like we should maybe just do Nadir.
这是——不，不，不，不。这些全都要保留。我们只是要做一期 Wordle 节目。对。两个软件工程师。对玩这个游戏过度思考。我觉得我们也许应该直接用 Nadir。
No, we're definitely not guessing a letter. That is a sub-op. I will guess found or hound way before I'll guess. Because we've only got 30 guesses in total. So you're throwing away 3% every single time you reuse a letter that you know is not in it. There's a very limited utility of the utility of each guess is. How about clown? I know it doesn't have your I.
不，我们绝对不会去猜一个已知不存在的字母。那是次优选择。比起去猜那个，我更倾向于猜 found 或 hound。因为我们总共只有 30 次猜测机会。所以每当你重复使用一个你知道不在其中的字母时，你就在浪费 3% 的机会。每个猜测的效用是非常有限的。Clown 怎么样？我知道它没有你的 I。
No. W, L, O. W's low probability. Yeah, yeah. I'm now looking at my bookshelf for ideas. P-L-A-I-D. Plaid. Plaid?
不。W、L、O。W 的概率很低。对，对。我现在正在看我的书架找灵感。P-L-A-I-D。Plaid。Plaid？
You like plaid? Not really. I think there's a better guess out there where they have a P. Oh, no, wait. A is in the same position. I don't like it. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. We can't do that. That was close. That was close. Wagon is another guess.
你喜欢 Plaid？其实还好。我觉得外面有更好的猜测，里面带一个 P。哦，不对，等一下。A 在相同的位置。我不喜欢。对，对，对，对。我们不能那样。好险。好险。Wagon 是另一个猜测。
That has an O in it, though, not an I. How about, um, disco, which has, but it has an S, so that's no good. Maybe we should just do found what's irritating or is right now i need i need to visualize this as like a scrabble rack with with blanks because like there's definitely a word like basin that is a is blank a blank i blank where one of those is an n for sure i mean we've already thought of a few basin nadir but all of those is an N for sure. I mean, we've already thought of a few,
不过里面有个 O，没有 I。也许我们应该直接选 found。烦人的是，现在我需要把这个想象成一个带有空白的拼字游戏架，因为绝对有一个像 basin 这样的词，它是 A，空白，A，空白，I，空白，其中一个肯定是 N。我是说，我们已经想过几个了，basin、Nadir，但所有这些里面要么有 R，要么有 S。这就是为什么我觉得第二个猜测最难，因为你有一组很强的限制条件。我是说，Wagon，从技术上讲我们可以猜 Wagon。等等，什么？W-A-G-O-N。我是说，我不喜欢它，因为 W 的概率非常低。
Basin, Nadir, but all of those either have an R in it or an S in it. So this is why I think the second guess is the hardest because it's like you have a strong set of requirements. I mean, Wagon, technically we could guess Wagon. Wait, what? W-A-G-O-N. I mean, I don't like it because W is very low probability.
等等，Wagon？你刚才说 Wagon 吗？对。你不觉得那是个词吗？不，我觉得那个词不该那样发音。Wagon？我觉得你的发音，你说的是 wagon。Wagon？
Wait, wagon? Did you just say wagon? Yeah. You don't think that's a word? No, I think that that's not how you pronounce that word. Wagon? I think the way that you pronounced it, you said wagon. Wagon?
Wagon？你刚才说 wagon。它是发音成——你刚才说 wagon。Wagon？Wagon？你说的是 wagon。有录音为证，你刚才说了 wagon。比起 found，我更喜欢 wagon 吗？我在想其他像 basin 这样的词。Cabin！哦！Cabin。
Wagon? You said wagon. It is pronounced it, you said wagon. Wagon? Wagon? You said wagon. It is on tape that you said wagon. Do I like wagon better than found? I'm trying to think of other words like basin. Cabin? Oh! Cabin.
Cabin？我是说，里面没有 D。对，我喜欢 cabin。好吧，我们就用它。我们考虑得够久了。扣动扳机吧。好的。我们有一个 C。
Cabin? I mean, it doesn't have a D in it. Yeah, I like cabin. Okay, let's do it. We've thought about this long enough. Let's pull the trigger. All right. We've got a C.
天哪。我差点就说出口了。所以我们现在把 cabin 输入进去了。C 是黄色的，这意味着有一个 C。A 是绿色的，这意味着我们可以。我知道它是什么。它绝对在第二个位置。B，中间有一个 B，嗯，嗯，这不是个中意的字母。然后是 I，
Holy fudge. I almost wore it. So we've now got, we put in cabin. The C is yellow, which means there is a C. The A is green, which means that we can. I know what it is. It's definitely in the second position. The B, there's B in the middle, um, uh, which is, uh, which was not a hit. And then there's I,
它在正确的位置，然后 N 是，嗯，嗯，黄色的。嗯，所以我们有一个 N。现在康纳确信他必须重新复盘。它是黄色、绿色、未命中、绿色、黄色。所以我们知道 A 和 I 的位置正确，C 和 N 的位置错误。所以我们只需要重新排列 C 和 N，我们已经知道它们只有两个地方可以去。我几乎百分之百确定我知道它是什么。如果你能想出来，我就让你自己想出来。你看，我本来打算把这段思考 Wordle 的过程剪掉，因为我觉得我们是在浪费时间，而且这很尴尬。然而，显然，显然在第二个猜测上花那么多时间，我们——哦，这太棒了，因为它验证了我的整个理论，即第二个猜测很重要，而且这全关于统计学。
which is in position and then N, which is, uh, uh, yellow. Um, so we have an N and so now Connor's convinced that he has to recap. It's yellow, green, a miss green, yellow. So we know the A and the I are in the right position and the C and the N are in the wrong position. So we only need to reorganize the C and the N, which we already know there's only two places those can go. I'm almost positive I know what it is. I'll let you figure it out if you can figure it out. And see, I was going to edit out this wordle thinking because I was like, we're wasting our time and this is embarrassing. However, clearly, clearly spending all that time on guest number two, we, we, oh, this is beautiful because it validates my whole theory of like the second guest is important and it's about statistics.
如果你想要一个关于这个词意思的提示。不，不，不，不要提示，不要提示。我也得在这个节目里显得聪明一点。让我们计算一下到底有多少种可能的组合。C 可以放在两个地方。N 可以放在两个地方。对。这意味着——我们已经猜了九个不同的字母。
If you want a hint about what the word means. Nope, nope, nope, no hints, no hints. I have to look, I have to look smart on this show, too. Let's calculate how many actual possibilities there are. The C can go in two places. The N can go in two places. Yeah. And then that means that there's, we've guessed, nine distinct letters.
所以我们假设全部 26 个减去 9 等于 17。所以 17 乘以 2 再乘以 2，我想。或者其实不是 2 乘以 2，因为当 C 放在某个特定位置时。是 panic 吗？我猜是这个，对。对，对。好吧，我们要把它输入进去吗？对，我们上吧。
And so we assume that all 26 minus 9 is 17. So 17 times 2 times 2, I think. Or it's actually not 2 times 2 because when the C goes in one position. Is it panic? That's my guess, yeah. Yeah, yeah. All right, are we putting it in? Yeah, let's do it.
我们以后每期都要玩 Wordle 吗？我们可能不得不这样。砰！砰！砰！哦，那个不错。那个不错。那个，那太棒了。对，看——哦，你——不要在同一个设备上玩，这就是我的意思，我总是用我的手机玩。哦，我等会儿用手机玩。因为那样可以保留战绩。哦，等等，等等。如果我用手机玩，现在我得记住我输入了什么，我们输入了什么。太棒了。
Are we going to do wordle every episode now we might have to boom boom boom oh that's a nice one that's a nice one that is that's wonderful yeah see oh you that's you don't do it from the same device that's what i mean is that i always do it from my phone oh i'll. I'll go do it from my phone later. Because then it keeps the stats. Oh, wait, wait. If I do it from my phone, now I have to remember what I put in, what we put in. That's great.
我喜欢。我们想到的那个以 P 开头的另一个词是什么来着？我记不起来了。Plaid。Plaid。哦，对。Plaid 其实也很棒。不如 Cabin。
I love it. What was the other word that started with a P that we were thinking about? I can't remember. Plaid. Plaid. Oh, yeah. Plaid would have been fantastic as well. Not as good as cabin.
Tears、Cabin。但是，是的，当布莱斯在敲打那些东西的时候，在拼字游戏中，我认为其中一个——来，让我——哦，对了，我们实际上要做的，我来共享屏幕，事情就是这样，我们考虑了一会儿，
Tears, cabin. But, yeah, so while have been fantastic as well. Not as good as Cabin. Tears, Cabin. But yeah, so while Bryce is typing that stuff in, in Scrabble, I think one of the, here, let me, let me, oh yeah, and actually what we'll do, I'll screen share, and that's the thing is, we were thinking about it for a while,
但我向你保证，大约有 200 个单词符合“空白-A-空白-I-空白”的格式。所以来，我快速共享屏幕。我要说的是，在拼字游戏中，用完你所有七个字母并形成一个成语（Bingo）的统计概率最高的一个词，我想大概是带有 D 的 satire。所以我现在在 wineverygame.com。这是一个单词生成器网站。所以如果我们输入空白、A、空白、I、空白，然后把它设为前缀，这样它就必须按这个顺序出现，我们会得到——我都数不清有多少个了。其实我们应该把它复制到 Excel 里。对，cabin 在里面。
but I guarantee you that there's like 200 words that follow the blank A, blank I. So here, let me quickly screen share. And what I was going to say was that in Scrabble, one of the most statistically likely to make a bingo using all seven of your letters is like satire with a D, I think. So I'm at wineverygame.com. This is like a word generator site. So if we go blank, A blank, I blank, and then we put that as the prefix so it has to show up in that order, we're going to get – I can't even count how many. Actually, we should copy it into Excel. Yeah, cabins there.
是 64 乘以 2 等于 128 减去 1 等于 127 个单词。不过，如果我们去掉那些不包含 S、R 和 T 的单词，看看还剩多少，其实会很有趣。我待会儿会算出来，并把它
It is 64 times 2 is 128 minus 1 is 127 words. Although if you omit the ones, it would actually be interesting if we omit the ones that don't have S's, R's, and T's in them, how many are left? I'll figure that out afterwards and
附在这一集的结尾，因为我有一个小的拼字游戏程序，我可以……所以这是来自未来的康纳。关于有多少个单词在第二或第四个位置包含 A 或 I 的答案是 49 个。我显然不会把它们全部读出来，但这 是基于拼字游戏词典（Scrabble dictionary）得出的。在 Wordle 词典中，它只包含拼字游戏词典的一小部分，大约 2500 个词，实际上只有 8 个，我会把它们读出来。它们分别是：cabin（也就是我们最后选择的那个）、manic、valid、magic、cavil、panic、vapid 和 final。除了 cavil 之外，这些词我都认识。我查了一下，它的意思是挑剔，也就是无理取闹地找岔子。
attach it to the end of this episode because I have a little Scrabble program where I can... So this is Connor from the future. The answer to how many words have either an A or an I in the second or fourth location is 49. I'm obviously not going to read all those out, but that is based on the Scrabble dictionary. In the Wordle dictionary, which only has a fraction of the Scrabble words, roughly 2,le dictionary, which only has a fraction of the Scrabble words, roughly 2,500, there is actually only eight, and I'll read those out. So those were cabin, which is the one we ended up choosing, manic, valid, magic, cavil, panic, vapid, and final. I knew all of those words except for cavil, which I looked up and means to carp, which that means to find fault unreasonably.
回到过去的康纳。哦，对。然后如果我们去——等等，等等，等等。回去。这是这个表格吗？对，对，对。我们正在看我的单词投资组合电子表格的“计划”标签页。
Back to past Connor. Oh, yeah. And then if we go... Wait, wait, wait. Go back. Is this the sheet? Yeah, yeah, yeah. We're looking at the plan tab of my portfolio of words spreadsheet.
里面有 2021 年。哦，等等。我们得更新一下。这是——我们正在看我的单词投资组合电子表格的“计划”标签页。里面有 2021 年。哦，等等。我们得更新一下。这是 2022 年，2023 年。显然，我是说，所有东西都更新过了。我已经读了三本书，看了 17 个小时的讲座。你让我觉得自己好懒。我们的阅读目标超前了 664%，讲座观看目标超前了 235%。这些公式里一定有错误。
And it's got 2021. Oh, wait. We got to update that. This is we're looking at the plan tab of my portfolio of words spreadsheet. And it's got 2021. Oh, wait, we got to update that. This is 2022, 2023. Obviously, I mean, everything has been updated. I've already read three books, watched 17 hours of lectures. You're making me feel so lazy. We're 664% ahead of our reading goals and 235% ahead of our lecture watching goals. There must be errors in those formulas.
没有。我们可以切换到视频标签页，实际查看所有视频的列表。看看所有的列表。就像今年的目标是——早上不要在沙发上、在我的沙发上打盹，也不要弄死那些我直属上司送给我们整个团队的小型空气凤梨。我觉得我在这两方面都失败了。我做不到。所以我想不出来。这绝对不是概率最高的七个字母，但是——
Nope. We can switch to the videos tab and actually watch the list of all. Look at all the lists. Like this year is like to stop taking naps on the couch on my couch in this morning and to not kill these little air plants that that my skip level sent to our whole team. I think I'm failing on both counts. I can't. So I can't figure out. This is definitely not the most likely seven letters but like
保留了，如果你有这些字母的单词 —— r-e-t-a-i-n-s，不用空白字母，你可以拼出九个不同的七字母单词，其中大多数我都不认识：anestry、antsier、nastier、retines、
retains if you have the letters for that words r-e-t-a-i-n-s without a blank letter you can spell nine different seven letter words most of which I don't know anestry, antsier, nastier, retines
retains、retinas、retcetsina、Stainer 和 Steerin。总之，关于拼字游戏和 Wordle 就说到这里。我绝对喜欢这个游戏。九战九胜，保持不败。而且我之前没意识到，大家说那个家伙的名字叫 Wordle，真的吗？我一无所知。我从新闻里听到的全部就是，他可能说过他永远不会在上面放广告，他会保持它的简单和免费，然后我知道另外一帮人或者公司试图抄袭这个游戏，结果他们又反悔了，把游戏下架了，说他们道歉了，嗯——我就是喜欢这种游戏问世的时候，而这个绝对是我的最爱，因为它构思太简单了。
retains, retinas retcetsina, Stainer, and Steerin. Anyways, enough about Scrabble and Wordle. I absolutely love this game. Nine for nine, undefeated. And I didn't realize, I thought that word that like, is it true that the guy's name is Wordle? I have no idea. All i've heard in the news is that he may said he's not going to ever put ads on it and he's going to keep it simple and free and then i know one other group of people or company tried to rip the game off and then they ended up backpedaling and taking the game down saying that they apologized and um i just i love when games like these come out and this one's got to be my favorite because it's such a simple idea.
他的姓是 Wardle，带有一个 A。所以——所以这个游戏的名字非常巧妙，因为听起来就像是一个，你知道的，适合文字游戏的可爱名字。但它同时也，你知道的，和他的姓氏非常接近。对，我觉得这是一个错失的良机，那就是没有——比如你只能——分享那些小小的表情符号真的非常非常可爱，但是——没有那种排行榜好友功能，比如你不能——他本应该稍微扩大一点影响力的，因为那样我们绝对会进入同一个 C++ 或者英伟达（Nvidia）人们的小排行榜。然后，我们就能
His last name is Wardle with an A. So so the name of the of the game is very clever because like it just seems like a, you know, a cute name for like a word game. But it's also like, you know, pretty close to his last name yeah what i think is is a missed opportunity is that there's no like you can only like the the sharing of the little emojis stuff is really really cute but like uh there's no sort of leaderboard friend thing like you can't sort of he should have amplified it a tiny bit more because then we definitely would be on the same little leaderboard of whatever c++ or n Nvidia people. And, and we'd get to,
看到彼此的成绩了。我觉得它——它——它，我觉得不，它保持简单优雅，纯粹，正是它成功的原因之一。对。
we get to see each other's. I think it's, it's, it's, I think no, the fact that it's simple and elegant, like in pure is one of the reasons why it's a successful thing. Yeah.
而且也许，也许不刻意扩大宣传正是引导人们去 Twitter 发推的原因。因为那是你分享它的唯一途径。所以也许它——也许它实际上因此变得更加流行和病毒式传播了。这是一个好点子。好的。我们已经录了多长时间了？已经 27 分钟了。所以我们要在第二集里展望 2022 年。所以我们本来应该在上周末做那个吗？我们本该做的，但是——所以我们的积压节目里已经有一两期了。
And actually maybe, maybe not amplifying it is what people leads people to Twitter to tweet it. Cause that's the only way you can kind of share it. So maybe it maybe it actually has become a more popular and viral because of that. That's a good point. All right. How long we've been recording for 27 minutes already. So we're going to we're going to we're going to do our looking ahead at the year 2022 in a second episode. So this is now we're supposed to do that last weekend? We were, but then... So we've already got like one or two episodes in the backlog.
这要么是第 62 期，要么是第 63 期，取决于我怎么剪辑。感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝你们有美好的一天。这期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。
This is either episode 62 or three, depending on how I edit things. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这到底是第62期还是第63期，取决于我怎么剪辑。谢谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝您有美好的一天。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。